from an uninspired live-action
adaptation of an animated classic to
Dwayne Johnson's ill-fated entry into
superheroderm the most disappointing
movies of 2022 ran the gamut from bad to
worse
filmmaker Joseph kazinski had an
eventful 2022 but then the space of a
month two of his films were released and
received major attention from the world
the first top gun Maverick annihilated
the box office bringing in
1.489 billion dollars and receiving near
Universal Acclaim from audiences and
critics the second release was a Netflix
film spider head written by Deadpool
scribes that reason Paul wernick and
starring Chris Hemsworth and Miles
Teller this sci-fi tin psychological
Thriller had all the makings of a smash
hit on the streaming service
unfortunately the movie belly flopped
upon release critical approval starts at
39 on Rotten Tomatoes while the audience
rating was even worse at 29 in the end
it didn't seem like many people watched
spiderhead either as a film struggled to
make Netflix's 10 most watched films of
2022 considering all the talent involved
and the reported budget of 100 million
dollars this is nothing short of a
massive disappointment
look let's be clear here no one ever
thought Michael Bay's ambulance was
going to be oscar-worthy material all
anyone expected was for Bay to run wild
and for there to be more slow-mo and
explosions and a 20-minute stretch and
most action franchises have across 10
movies surprisingly ambulance became
tied with the rug as the best reviewed
Bay film on Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
Mystic tightness switching between total
bayhem and a heart-wrenching story in a
cohesive and natural manner so why then
did no one watch it ambulance had a
reported 40 million dollar budget
according to variety but it labored to a
52 million worldwide gross while no one
expected the film to reap the same
numbers as the Bay directed Transformers
franchise there was an expectation that
it would still turn a decent profit
unfortunately despite being one of Bay's
better films ambulance struggled to find
an audience and it became a high-profile
box office flop
Disney has been on a drive to create
live-action adaptations of his classic
animated films so it came as no surprise
that in 2022 the studio released a
live-action version of Pinocchio rather
than being a magical experience however
it felt like Disney executive's noses
grew longer for lying to themselves that
this would somehow work jump
ER directed by Robert zemakis and
starring Tom Hanks as Geppetto and
Joseph Gordon-Levitt as Jiminy Cricket
it's almost difficult to Fathom how this
all went pear-shaped producing wooden
performances from all those involved in
the film in slash films review of
Pinocchio critic Vanessa Armstrong said
as a parent myself if faced with the
choice of watching this film again with
my child versus caving into her request
to watch Frozen for the 35th millionth
time I would and hesitatingly get ready
to hear Let It Go it's universally
agreed that Guillermo del Toro's
adaptation of Pinocchio for Netflix is a
far better 2022 adaptation of the famous
Italian fable
on paper The Gray Man had all the
makings of the next big spy franchise
directed by the Russo brothers and
starring Ryan Gosling Chris Evans and
Anna dayamas this was a big movie for
Netflix the streaming giant even
committed 200 million dollars to get it
made according to deadline despite all
the Pomp and Circumstance surrounding
the film The Gray Man spluttered like a
retread of every Spy Trope known to
mankind there is hardly anything
original about the film or its
predictable plot but the biggest
highlight being Evan's Mighty mustache
which proves he may have been the right
Chris to portray Mario in the Super
Mario Brothers movie
without a shadow of a doubt filmmaker
taika waititi breathed new life into the
God of Thunder with Thor Ragnarok
suddenly thawing from being one of the
blandest Avengers to the funniest and
most exciting that's why TT captured the
spirit of artists Jack Kirby's Cosmic
Adventures as a result the expectations
went through the roof of the follow-up
film thought love and thunder however
Thor love and thunder proved to be one
of the mcu's most divisive films upon
release with a critical approval rating
of 63 on Rotten Tomatoes it's also the
lowest rated Thor film in the franchise
writing for CNET reviewer Richard
trenholm criticized how the film values
gags over any form of emotional impact
writing love and thunder is just too
flippant why should we feel anything
when clearly none of it matters the
criticism is one shared by many viewers
of the film who felt the themes of Love
and Death in particular were buried
under the Avalanche of goofy jokes
that was an air of anticipation around
blonde when it was first announced
everything pointed towards it being a
fabulous biography of the woman born
Norma Jean Mortensen who changed the
course of the entertainment industry yet
when the reviews trickled in the
critical response to blonde was divisive
to further illustrate the points the
film was nominated for both an Academy
Award and several razzies many viewers
add their displeasure with blonde and
how it seemingly doesn't respect Marilyn
Monroe's Legacy critics were equally
hesitant to embrace the film Tanya gold
of the new Statesman wrote watching
blonde it feels like writer Joyce Carol
Oates and director Andrew Dominic hate
Marilyn Monroe in this film's telling
she is doomed from the beginning made of
pain
Jurassic world Dominion promised to be
the big finale to the Blockbuster series
the film capped off the new Trilogy
bringing back fun favorites Sam Neil
Laura Dern and Jeff Goldblum from the
original films this was the last hurray
while the humans would scream and run
away from the hungry Velociraptors and
other dangerous creatures in other words
it was meant to be a good time for
everyone except the characters on screen
well Jurassic world Dominion made Bank
by earning over 1 billion dollars at the
box office it's still the lowest earning
film in the new Trilogy it also has a
dishonor of being considered the worst
reviewed film in the franchise with
critics only handing it a 29 approval
rating on Rotten Tomatoes sure the
dinosaur Carnage still makes it a fun
albeit mindless watch but it wasn't the
Epic finale this franchise deserved
in Years Gone by creating a Disney
animated film was the equivalent of
printing money children and parents
would lap up each release and hit the
theaters in droves to absorb every
single second of these endearing movies
Don Hall's Strange World had all the
elements necessary for it to become a
huge mega hit as well a star-studded
cast check a cute animal check great
animation check a story bursting with
huge amounts of action comedy and
Adventure triple check yet somehow
Strange World struggled to capture the
attention of the wider audience as it
was Dead on Arrival within his first
week of released in theaters according
to variety The Animated feature cost in
a region of 180 million dollars to
produce but it only managed to make just
over 73 million dollars worldwide due to
these shockingly low numbers it became a
huge flop for Disney losing the studio a
significant amount of money
Jared Leto in a comic book movie what
could possibly go wrong after lato's
Joker and the DC EU became the
laughingstalk of Suicide Squad for his
behind the scenes method acting nonsense
morbius presented him with a unique
opportunity to right the wrongs of the
past he had the opportunity to play Dr
Michael morbius a brilliant scientist
who becomes a living vampire and is one
of the coolest anti-heroes in Marvel
Comics considering the fact that lato
doesn't seem to age either this seems
like perfect casting alas that would be
both the beginning and the end of the
film's Perfection morbius isn't the
worst superhero film ever made it gets a
lot of a necessary flag for cardinal
sins that even the MCU commits but it
fails to build upon Sony's Spider-Man
universe the Daniel Espinosa directed
film doesn't have the charm or appeal of
Venom and it also seems unsure of where
it fits in the continuity of anything
really it's simply there without any
Rhyme or Reason for its existence
oh boy the fans were upset about
Halloween kills were not prepared for
this finale at all as the last entry in
David Gordon Green's Trilogy Halloween
ends as meant to serve as an exclamation
mark on the franchise as a whole it's a
final battle between Laurie Strode and
Michael Myers where only one of them
will walk out alive but it's everything
before the climactic end that upsets
many viewers instead of focusing on the
Strode family or even Michael himself
the story makes Corey Cunningham the
central protagonist of the movie The
Haddonfield Outsider has an encounter
with Michael in the sewers and survives
Corey doesn't embrace the fact he's
alive or that he'd Live to Tell The Tale
But he somehow becomes inspired to
become a murderer after looking into
Michael's eyes at one point they even
team up to kill a couple because reasons
reviewers and fans alike were left
scratching their heads of the decision
to close Halloween with this peculiar
narrative angle the Hollywood reporter's
David Rooney said this is a sloppy movie
whose principal new inspiration feels
bogus
whenever Damien chazelle releases a film
bet good money on it securing at least
one Oscar nomination Babylon continues
this trend however it might be the
filmmaker's most polarizing effort
judging by the 56 critical approval
rating and 52 audience scoring Rotten
Tomatoes costing 78 million dollars to
produce Babylon is also giselle's most
expensive picture to date unfortunately
it could only crawl to 31 million
dollars worldwide Hollywood loves
nothing more than films about Hollywood
and that's exactly what Babylon is it
showcases an era of Tinseltown in which
to privacy and Indulgence run rampant
well at least more so than now at over 3
hours in length though not even Margot
Robbie or Brad Pitt could attract the
audience to watch this self-indulgent
film about the world's most
self-indulgent industry and
I'm going to bed but why did it
disappoint so many fans maybe just maybe
the audience doesn't want to pay to
watch an elephant defogate on screen
to be fair the lead up to Fantastic
Beasts the secrets of Dumbledore was
riddled with more controversy and plot
twists than an episode of Days of Our
Lives Harry Potter Creator JK Rowling
came under Fire for her repeated
anti-trans statements Ezra Miller went
on a crime spree in Hawaii and the
producers had to recast the role of Gala
Grindelwald as a result of Johnny Depp's
ongoing legal troubles Paul Bettany is a
good friend
yes you've done drugs with him yes I
have unfortunately the actual movie
itself like the Gusto or Panache to
excel in spite of all the drama making
just over 400 million dollars is the
lowest grossing film in The Wizarding
World Series critics weren't enamored by
it either unless it says for the less
than Stellar score of 46 on Rotten
Tomatoes after the low box office
performance and largely an enthused
reception towards the film Warner
Brothers Discovery chose to carefully
consider what to do next to the
Wizarding World as a whole thus pumping
the brakes on any future entries in the
series
before Black Adam was released Dwayne
Johnson proclaimed on Instagram that the
status quo of the DC Universe was about
to change it was a gutsy move to ignite
interest in the film and he even managed
to secure Henry cavill's Superman to
return for a glorious Cameo which cost
Warner Brothers Discovery a pretty penny
unfortunately the studio turmoil and
constant game of musical chairs in the
executive boardrooms didn't Inspire much
confidence in the film from the start
while the comic book movie was a dud
with critics the fan reaction was far
more positive with most viewers
embracing it as a fun popcorn flick
money is all that matters in Hollywood
though and Black Adam didn't make enough
of the green to satisfy the Studio's
accountants with the production Caster
reported 260 million dollars per The
Hollywood Reporter the film only managed
to make 393 million dollars worldwide in
the end Black Adam didn't kick-start a
new era in the DC Universe as Johnson
announced on Twitter that his character
would not be a part of James Gunn's and
Peter sufferin's first phase of the DCU
[Music]
foreign